we're creating bbq style beef brisket
with crunchy coleslaw and sweet potato
wedges which will be right up her street
holly
now
you love barbecues right
so gonna help me barbecue this delicious
piece of brisket brisket
look at it
beautiful it's a very tough cut of meat
so it needs to be cooked slowly so it
gets really nice and tender are we
barbecuing it outside we're gonna
actually put the barbecue flavor on
there but we're gonna cook it in the
oven
okay
so mustard powder
okay
here we have some celery seed
next
a little bit of salt in there
okay what's this here cumin two again
nice good now this one
cayenne pepper absolutely right right
two teaspoons of that in there as well
good
now what i want you to do
fresh pepper on there
i'll give that a little mix
roll up your little sleeves and then
i want you
to rub
all that spice
into the brisket
almost like you're massaging it in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there good girl
now that's nice and coated okay
in the spice
so gas on roasting tray on what we've
got to do now with all those spices is
sear them in a couple of tablespoons of
olive oil into the tray
well done good that's getting nice and
hot now you get your brisket
and all that spice
lay that in there nicely
okay so now
we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in
you smell those spices yep all that
spice left on the plate
we're gonna use yeah
i want you to get the onions
nice and carefully
slice them down not too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
smell those spices now
good girl
thank you wash my hands i can rub my eye
damn holly
was homework that bad
no the onions oh no don't rub your eyes
don't rub your eyes
[Music]
we've got the colour
on the brisket okay yeah
take that out literally for 30 seconds
okay
onions into the tray please
nice
you see it's starting to smell slightly
barbecuey already give that a little
stir
nice
now one nice tablespoon of brown sugar
what does the brown sugar do for the
brown sugar i'm gonna start caramelizing
the onions
right from there my bailey's in please
good girl oh yes please
right you want to take over
good careful that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon
of tomato puree roast that off at the
bottom of the tray to really rub it in
amongst the onions good girl
now look at the color of the onions
right now
time for a little drink
for the brisket
okay one bottle of beer in please
so you go in you put yours in there i'll
put mine here
good uh good health to you and your
brisket
good health
bring that to the ball
okay now this is where it gets really
exciting i want you to lift the brisket
up and put it on top of the onions in
she goes
good girl
and then i want you to pour the stock
all the way around please
i'm using beef stock but it will work
with chicken stock or even vegetable
stock
once the stock has come to the boil
cover tightly with foil
and just pinch in the ends
flatten that down and then you just
twist
all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
first job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds until beautifully
aromatic
then put them in a pestle and mortar add
salt and grind
[Music]
next smoked paprika dried oregano
cayenne pepper and mix
spice mix done now simply cut your sweet
potatoes into wedges toss in olive oil
and thoroughly cover with the spice
mix onto a baking tray and into a
preheated oven for 30 minutes turning
halfway
irresistible sweet potato wedgies are
ready now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh
ah
now look at that so we can leave that to
rest what does resting mean resting
means where you've cooked a joint and
you just leave it to relax so it'll make
the meat so much more tender okay right
coleslaw traditionally you would mix
slaw with what
mayonnaise that's right mayonnaise this
time we're gonna do it a little
different so i'd like to put the yogurt
into the bowl for me
please all of it i'll start slicing the
white cabbage
and the red cabbage now from there a
nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up
nice little touch
of salt and pepper
okay
now
a little cider vinegar so a little
splash of cider vinegar
in there okay as i shred this okay i'd
like you please
then to get the
red cabbage and just open up into that
and mix in at the same time and then you
fold that in there as i start shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now the
white
so
you've got that nice vinegary
tartness to the slaw and the yogurt
keeps it nice and fresh
nice little bit in
one more little thing
so
put some nice
chopped
fresh chives in there and that will give
you this nice light
onion flavor
so
chives in
[Music]
how's that now taste it with the chives
in there
delicious so
i would like you
to fill up the bowl i'm going to very
carefully lift out
my brisket how comes it shrunk
it's been in the oven
for nearly
three and a half hours
so it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
i'll start slicing it and see how soft
look at that
and here's the thing about helping daddy
cook
here's the perk
you get to taste it first
before anybody
that is so good
that
tastes delicious
see all that wonderful flavor in there
last job is to create an incredibly
quick and delicious sauce
gas on and reduce the spicy juices and
onions the beef cooked in
then add in cider vinegar and you've got
a brilliant tangy barbecue sauce
that smells nice doesn't it
wow
that is brisket
and a half now the rest of it
you can go in the gravy pot
that's a really nice rich
spicy
barbecue
onion gravy
that my darling
is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready
if you carry
the sweet potato for me i've got the
brisket wow
let's go donny well done by the way
thank you
this is a real american beauty gorgeous
low and slow cooked barbecue beef
brisket with three potato wedges and
yogurt coleslaw
megan jack
tilly big deep smoky flavors that bring
the taste of the american south to your
kitchen
here's my favorite beef and ale with
mustard dumplings
[Music]
and helping in the kitchen is my
youngest tilly
[Music]
tilly
first things first i'd like you to
season
the stewing steak
a nice spoon of flour
mix yeah
good girl what's the flower going to do
dad the flower helps to brown the beef
our seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor and thicken the stew
i feel a bit like marshmallows
they do feel a little bit marshmallow
don't they look at the size of the
chunks of the beef
i'm going to cut my carrots literally be
similar similar size that's right does
that mean they'll cook equally that's
right now these are little pearl onions
i'm going to put them in hole as well
everything
has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn oh we've seen
burned garlic before
oh matilda
she promised you weren't going to
mention that what is that
time
time and what are they
bay leaves bailey's good girl tablespoon
of oil in
the beef goes in first okay
in
a really nice color got a beautiful
color
remember the carrots thyme in
good girl
garlic pearl onions in
good
give that a really good mix up
[Music]
daddy stews are very easy to make
providing at the beginning to give it a
little bit of love
now that's all beautifully browned
that bin that is beer and that's going
to deglaze the pan
adding beer or stout helps to tenderize
the beef and give it a hearty delicious
flavor
and that's the only way i want you to
taste beer
in a stew
yeah
i'm going to add in a couple of
teaspoons of tomato puree please
in fact three please
because it's so nice there's one final
thing in there
cover the steering state with the bee
stock give that a little mix with daddy
please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you um serve it to be
oh yes is the garlic going to be burnt
no excuse me
right and we always put the lid with a
little bit just a little bit so it can
breathe that's right not make the stew
all watery into the oven at 150 please
teals for about two and a half hours and
now
you can focus on your homework
fun
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato classics in one twice baked
bubbling squid jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute in butter and add a dash of
water until tender
[Music]
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and cook
through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato center
then mash with a couple of knobs of
butter mix in the cabbage and season to
taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
[Music]
right homework done yep beef juice
chewing stewing let's get on with our
delicious hearty pet art i've been
looking forward to this
you and i chef i'm gonna prep the pears
so if you peel
i'll top and tail
into quarters pears go soft in the oven
very very quickly so we're going to put
them on a tart you'll need to leave them
whole half or in quarter
what's that in there
ginger that's right a stem ginger so you
stem ginger and fresh ginger
next add your stem ginger a little of
the stem ginger syrup good girl and some
brown sugar to your quartered pears
and then just grab some fresh ginger off
you go so it's a bit of a
different one to grate this because it
doesn't really come through like the
cheese no
i'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there
right what we need to do now is give
that
a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff where you make it it's so
easy to do so give me your finger
that's my center point i want you to get
the pears going around
like that in a really nice circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pairs keep on sliding all over the place
yeah
we've egg washed the outside and i'm
going to show you a little trick
so you lift that up so see egg wash
acting like a bit of a glue that's right
crimple this with our finger
and the paste performs this nice little
shelf
like a little money bag are you going to
do anything with the spare pears oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
we've got the fresh ginger
and those nice little bits of stem
ginger
let me get round mike with your glue we
might glue just on top
tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully it's a bit like snow isn't
it now that glaze is the pastry so the
pastry has this really nice shine on
there as well finally the lemon on top
and then put that there
180 and in she goes
you smell the beef smells delish
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it look at that i want you to
just i was hoping you'd ask just have a
little taste
[Music]
how's that taste now
i'm not allowed anymore
dumpling time flour in please i'm using
self-raising flour for a fluffy result
but if you like your dumplings hard use
plain flour
next the dumpling essential suet
that makes the dumplings nice and moist
thank
you followed by a generous dollop of
grain mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers round and i've
got a touch of warm water here
your fingers are now a nice little whisk
your fingers are getting tired right now
put your hand in there now you should
bring
all that dough together
i'll show you the best way to get that
nice and clean sprinkle the flour on
your hands rub them together
all that will come off
that's a good way isn't it
now you've got this wonderful dumpling
mixture
how squidgy is that
a little flour on your hands okay
roll these lengthways
and then i want you to
fall in like that in your hand
off we go
smell that mustard in there
huh
come on you never trust you with
something like that
yes please
silly
gently
let's go in
at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center
put that back into the oven for 20
minutes to cook the dumplings now if you
open the door for daddy i'm going to
take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our pear tart has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby
that looks good
would you like me to start dusting yes
please
nice and gently all the way around good
girl
little taps
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job
now very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look
delicious okay i'll check on the
dumplings
now
look
they've sort of doubled in size
whoa definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
i might have to have a quick taste
before we go
just to check i mean we don't have to be
sure we have to be very sure
[Music]
that is an amazing hearty beef stew with
dumplings right the twice baked loaded
potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate hearty dinner a
comforting rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and ginger galette
on the menu is a succulent rare beef
fillet with salsa velvee
served with roasted truffle new potatoes
dishes designed to make your special
occasion one to remember
and to end our ramsay get together with
a bang i've enlisted willing sous chef
jack
to help me make us a blind chocolate and
pistachio semi-freddo
now i know you love chocolate right
we'll break this up so it melts nice and
evenly
all right that goes over a memory and
you can't put the chocolate in direct
contact with the gas yeah okay otherwise
it will split crack four eggs in that
food blooper of course hold on like that
on the side and then your fingers in
and pull out okay
good
nice now you're cracking eggs with one
hand
nice one i need some muscles okay start
whisking and i'll fold in a bit of sugar
come on let's do 30 seconds each ready
okay
come on jack give it some 13 year old
welly come on some muscles
10 seconds to go nine eight
seven six
five
four
three
two
one all right here we go your turn for
sugar let's go
you see the secret to whisking
vigorously is changing hands every ten
seconds yep now i'm gonna start the
chocolate i'll stir that up
now the secret behind this is getting it
really nice and thick and that's like
established okay your turn come on
change change again yeah of course also
the chocolate leave that to slightly
cool down a touch
from there
cream in
why putting the cream in separately
because i'm gonna get it nice and thick
first if you start whisking that i'm
gonna get in the vanilla
to maximize the flavor from a vanilla
bean cut the pot in half lengthways and
scrape out those wonderfully aromatic
seeds
for extra flavor put the pod in as well
but remember to take it out once it's
infused
so we've got three components the melted
chocolate yes sugar yes and the eggs
whipped up
and the cream with the vanilla
next mix in your melted chocolate with
the sugar and egg saby on so you got a
nice
rich
chocolate ganache smell how delicious
i'm now i'm putting the cream and so you
just
whisk that in
now look at that how gorgeous is that
looking
and that my son
here's a chocolate semi-freddo
now they taste
[Music]
pistachios right sprinkle them in
now get your baking tray you line that
with cling film so it's easy to pull out
once it sets and then you just pour that
in
that is a real treat
so you fold that over okay this is like
ice cream in any way yeah as it sets
you slice it it's like this nice
chocolate ice block delicious
then put your semifredo into the freezer
for around three hours to set
right jack get that pan nice and hot
recognize that fillet of beef this is a
rolls-royce cup of beef so we've got to
treat it with some respect okay yeah mop
up all that seasoning yeah
into the pan
and get that really nice and hot hello
till guys
kiss mmm kiss
[Music]
little bit of garlic and thyme in there
cooking with these aromatic herbs and
garlic will add flavor to the beef
because it's a fillet of beef there's
hardly any fat on there so you sear it
quickly
ends as well gets seared i'm gonna now
put some butter in there
continue frying all those herbs
now
baste that with the butter
see dad are we just having this or are
we gonna have something with it now
we're gonna serve some beautiful baked
potatoes with truffle and a salsa verde
into the oven eight to ten minutes
that's all
next my super special baked new potatoes
wash and drain small new potatoes and
tip into a baking tray
drizzle with olive oil then season with
a touch of salt and freshly ground black
pepper
place into an oven preheated at 180
degrees celsius and bake for 35 minutes
until crisp on the outside and soft all
the way through
transfer to your serving dish and grate
over fresh parmesan cheese
last but not least shave gorgeous earthy
black truffle slivers onto the cheesy
potatoes
bake new potatoes with a lavish twist
indulgent but couldn't be simpler to
make
[Music]
right sounds a birthday anchovies little
touch of anchovy oil in there okay i
love anchovies after that we've got some
capers
garlic
in with the anchovies and the capers
okay a touch
of salt one only a touch because you
could just soften the actually that's
right well then holes diesel mustard
sherry vinegar give that a nice mix
now this is where it starts to go to a
completely different level some fresh
mint and some fresh parsley i want half
of it in there
pureed
a touch of olive oil in there in
the rest of the mint
a touch of salt
pepper
excited yeah
no taste
i'd love some of these
what's it taste like
fat
oh
might need to try a tiny bit more
just to check
stop
you can't kiss any boys now
before the kids polish off all the
sounds of elderly i need a distraction
and i think my b phillip will do the job
nicely
look at this baby hot holes
up
look at that
seared and look how juicy
and tender that is take that out and let
that sit
on there a little spoon just while it
sits and rests obviously so early
as the beef cools down that south of the
other marinades that
goes to the table very carefully please
teals taking over the baked potatoes
please all right send me photo
now
look at that nice
[Applause]
wow and then you just get your chocolate
and you grate it
[Music]
she's gorgeous
how delicious is that let's get one do
not drop that please okay i'm going up
to my bedroom now jack
this is my ultimate special occasion
dinner
the tenderest rare beef fillet with
punchy salsa velde
served with extravagant truffled new
potatoes
and a sublime chocolate pistachio
semifredo
[Music]
you